washington journal continues
joining us from fort lauderdale florida
is author brad meltzer he has written a
number of nonfiction books but now out
with a number of fiction books his new
non-fiction the first conspiracy the
secret plot to kill george washington
we'll get to the book in just a moment
but first from your observation looking
at the shutdown here in washington now
entering week four
what are your observations
uh you know i'm on book tour right now
which means i am going and seeing
everyone who's working in airports on a
daily basis
and i can tell you
that
all you see people doing is saying thank
you to the tsa people we know what's
going on and we all want to you know
turn this into something political we
always turn everything in this country
into something political but there are
just uh you know this is always our
government is always us and it is made
up of us and what you're seeing is um
real people going through real problems
right now the other thing you'll see we
had an event at the national archives
that was canceled earlier in the week
because of course the national archives
is closed
and about the only good thing i can make
of this thing is there's no traffic
downtown in washington dc other than
that you got people
um you know who are really and listen i
was someone who grew up in a working
class family i was the first in my
family to go to a four-year college and
we live month to month my dad only paid
i remember when my dad got paid
i knew it because he brought home the
dry cleaning he couldn't afford to pick
up the dry clean until he got his check
and that's how most of us live
and you know this is not a time i i wish
the president knew but this is not a
time where you can ask your dad for
money um there are real people out there
with real problems and i really hope
that we can figure this out because
throwing tantrums and holding your
breath over over the wall you want is
not helping all these amazing people and
again whatever your politics are it's
not about republican democrat here at
this moment but just remember that there
are real people out there on both sides
um who are really going to be going
through some hard times right now do you
see an endgame to this
um i don't an end game is different than
the ending um you know the end game is
basically empower embarrass the other
side that's what they're playing right
now right they want someone to blink
they want uh president trump to look bad
because then he doesn't look like a good
deal maker and he can't move and he's
done the uh
you know the read my lips of uh 2019
and uh on the other side they want to
see the democrats you know embarrass
them and show their they can't negotiate
with me i'm the greatest negotiator of
all time
so that's the that's the end game
as for the ending
it's just a question of of who's going
to blink first
let's talk about your book and our first
president the book is titled the first
conspiracy and let me focus first on
george washington and then we'll talk
about the plot against him you write the
following quote honor honor honor so
much of george washington's life has
been centered around the pursuit of this
ideal it's perhaps the greatest lesson
from his youth honor or something you
can take anywhere and it will never let
you down
yeah and listen i i know it's you know
the obviously the plot of the book is
called
is subtitled the secret plot to kill
george washington but what was vital to
myself and josh ment who i worked on
this book with
is that you get to see the depth of his
character and one of my favorite moments
in the book is showing where he comes
from
he is not someone who grew up with a lot
of money
he was you know we what we do with our
heroes in america today is we dip them
in granite we build great statues of
them
and they become dead and they're not
human anymore and we do no service to
any of our heroes because any hero you
look up to whether it's george
washington whether it's dr king whether
it's rosa parks
had a moment where they were scared and
terrified where they didn't think they
can go on but they did and for george
washington it was always about honor
one of my favorite moments in the book
is you'll see him at the battle of
brooklyn
and one of the things you see is you
know we think george washington's the
greatest leader of all time he's the
best general and and you know we just
joined hands and beat the british the
greatest fighting force that the world
has ever known but in reality in the
battle we got our rear ends kicked
george washington got out generaled
he didn't have the experience that the
british generals had
but what he did have and what he always
does and in that moment let's be clear
you know he's pinned down he's got the
british in front of him he's got the
east river behind him this is the end
game this is the end game right this is
the moment where it's all done
and he could have beaten his chest and
show what a big man he is
said let's take out as many as we can
and we'll show them all up and uh and
we'll go out in a blaze of glory
but you know george washington isn't
macho like that he doesn't you know
there's no there's nothing macho about
that there's nothing manly about that
instead he does
the best thing he always does is he
plans a daring escape he basically
adapts the best thing he always does is
he makes a new plan and adapts and in
the middle of the night they commandeer
every boat along the east river
and what they do and this is the key
moment is george washington slowly
putting his troops on board but he will
not put any of his troops on board
uh he won't he won't get on board
himself until all of his troops are
aboard and away safely so his troops see
that he's risking his own life to make
sure that they're safe and that is honor
that is taking care of other people
before yourself that is the depth of his
character
another person featured in your book
another figure from american history
john jay you write the following
throughout the entire revolutionary era
few men can claim as many titles and
will play as many different critical
roles as john jay staying mostly above
the fray and commanding almost universal
respect
yeah you know listen this is a plot to
kill george washington and i found this
story nearly a decade ago when i was
looking through the footnotes and i was
like is this a true story a you know a
plot to kill washington and it was true
and let's just you know so i can set up
the john j part in 1776 there was a plot
to kill george washington when george
washington found out about it he
gathered up those responsible he took
one of the co-conspirators and in a
field an open field hung them hanged
them i should say in front of 20 000
people the largest public execution at
that point in north american history
george washington brought the hammer
down and i became obsessed with this
story especially
saying how to get out of it who caught
them how'd they figure it out and that's
where john jay comes in because one of
the first things that washington did is
he formed a secret committee
and when you form a secret committee
you've got to have a good name for the
secret committee
his name they picked was the committee
on conspiracies and john jay was put in
charge of it uh he was there with three
of them eventually that that really were
in charge it was john jay governor
morris and philip livingston and these
were the three that george washington
trusted most
and in this moment what john jay does is
they're literally going in the middle of
the night they're kicking down doors
they're pulling people out they're
interrogating them but in the process as
they're trying to figure out this plot
what they're really doing is they're
building america's first
counterintelligence agency
and you know john jay of course goes on
to become the first supreme court
justice in the united states but the
reason he gets the job is because see
what he does helping george washington
uncover this plot and the many after it
and as they build this agency
you know right now we think we ask
historians what the precursor to the cia
is and many will tell you oh it's the
oss but it's not true it all comes from
this moment where john jay is helping
uncover this plot and everything he does
after in fact right now in langley
virginia at cia headquarters there is a
room dedicated to john jay who they call
the founding father of
counterintelligence and i love that you
get to see
just uh what john jay is capable of
because he's one of those just really
true underdog hidden heroes we all know
him for the intellectual side um but at
this moment at the start of the war he
is just one of the great unsung heroes
of figuring out this plot to go against
washington brad meltzer let's then get
to the heart of the book and this plot
uh to kill george washington you write
the following quote there is a
traitorous plan against him he has no
idea it's coming since the day he was
appointed to his command general
washington had a nearly impossible task
to organize a scattered mess of
backwoods militias and untrained
volunteers into a functioning national
army to stand up to what is probably the
biggest and most powerful military force
in the world and of course great britain
so what happened
so what happens is uh you know first we
got to ask why does no one know this
story
right it is the first conspiracy that's
the title of the book of course but it's
truly um our first conspiracy that's
there in america at the time and what's
amazing to me is how it happens and
who's responsible because what what
happens is george washington has his own
personal bodyguards
and he asked all of his top regiments
says give me your four best men
and he wants what they call drilled men
he wants the best of the best
and what he does is he personally george
washington himself narrows all those men
down to about 50 of them
and those 50 become what they call the
generals guard they call them the
commander's guard but what they're
really eventually known as the name that
sticks are the lifeguards
because one of their jobs is to guard
truly george washington's life
and these are the men who turn on george
washington these are the ones who are
involved with the plot to kill him and i
don't care that you become the greatest
general i don't care that you become the
first president okay how strong we all
say you are that is a moment that is
devastating to george washington
and we start with that and when that
happens
uh as you said
we think again that it's you know we
when we tell the story
of the american revolution we love to
tell the story that you know
it was the british were here and we
banned it together we took them down
there was a declaration from the penance
is george washington we win the
constitution he's the president the end
we live happily ever after but it's
never that simple we think we're divided
today as a country in 1776
i can tell you that in new york city
where the first great battles took place
when the british were invading that
there were nearly as many
loyalists on the british side as there
were patriots on the american side and
it was no different in our own military
what you can see is that the regiments
from massachusetts fought with the
regiments from connecticut fought with
the regiments from virginia one of my
favorite scenes in the first conspiracy
as you'll see in harvard yard
that george washington arrives in
harvard yard and all the different
regiments are coming together and you
see the regiments from massachusetts
meet the regiments from virginia the
virginians wear these kind of frilly
things on their uniforms and like people
from massachusetts of course i got a
mouth off from it i used to live there
myself and of course a fight breaks out
and of course they're fighting like
crazy george washington rides in on his
horse hops off the horse grabs two of
the biggest guys by the neck he's
shaking them and basically saying
stop fighting with each other we're on
the same team
and if ever there are a metaphor for
where we are today this is it right it's
happening right there
and back then you know we have
politicians today again whatever your
politics are
who love to drape themselves in the flag
and tell you how patriotic they are
there was no american flag back then
there was no united states back then
george washington had to help build it
by putting his arms around this and
grabbing everyone and bringing them
together taking this utter chaos and
trying to turn it into these united
states
and it was by no means easy for him
because what he's dealing with
are 10 000 men descending on new york
city
right this is where the first big
battles are taking place guess what 10
000 men want to do
when they're not with their wives the
same thing 10 000 men would do today
when they're not with their wives they
want to gamble they want to drink back
then they're going to prostitutes and
george washington is a proper virginian
gentleman he's horrified by this he sees
what's happening you can see his general
orders of the day his general orders
were the rules of what come down every
day and he you know there are no rules
in the military he's building the
military you know bit by bit and his
first ones that are coming down among
them are no gambling he hates gambling
stop drinking
no prostitutes the same rules my parents
had for me growing up right i mean that
all of us have but but you know i make a
joke but
the this is what george washington is
contending with again he's trying to
bring all of this together
and again he's the one who builds this
so we don't have you know we know that
the when leaders pull us together
they're the best of us when they pull us
apart they're the worst of us brad
meltzer joining us from fort lauderdale
his latest book the first conspiracy the
secret plot to kill george washington
and in the book to that point you write
the following although many new york
city residents cheer on washington and
the new continental army there also are
many who don't support them new york is
a major power center for the loyalists
you go on to write the fact that so many
colonists have been lured to join the
secret army must be deeply frustrating
and distressing this act of betrayal on
part of his own soldiers must weigh on
general washington's soul literally
nothing could be further from this ideal
of honor we'll go to john joining us in
west palm beach florida good morning
good morning brad just up the road from
you and
a couple of comments you made i mean
you're making them wonderful wonderful
points and then you say something that i
just say what
i'm in the flag yes they didn't have a
flag at the very very beginning but they
did have a flag
and as far as that first comment at the
beginning about trump trying to thump
his chest uh he ran on
the wall he made it an issue
and the democrats if anyone are the ones
that are trying to thwart that um i mean
what are we talking about 5.7 divided by
4 trillion dollar budget is 1
250th of a percent
so let's let's do the math there that's
that's kind of silly to make that point
that you first made at the beginning
there but what you are saying is very
true
as far as uh you know nothing's changed
really except the uh the wardrobes as
far as history goes and as harry truman
said the only thing new is the history
you haven't learned and unfortunately in
this country
there's so many illiterate people
that don't think
as far as history goes that don't think
history is worth learning so i applaud
you for bringing out washington he is
our greatest president because without
him we wouldn't have any other
presidents everybody talks about lincoln
but they forget he shut down 200
newspapers which i wasn't too crazy
about learning when i was in college so
thank you very much i look forward to
reading your book thank you john no and
i appreciate it and and john i really
appreciate it especially what you said
about history and just to also be clear
about i actually didn't say that about
trump when i talked about beating his
chest um play it back what i said is
george washington didn't beat his chest
i didn't mention any president um you
saw trump in that one and uh and that's
i think the telling part is i say the
word you don't have to beat your chest
um and we project who we see and i think
like any historical figures that's what
we always do with history right what any
historical hero is to us what any
historical villain is to us is um they
are mirrors and we hold them up and you
see what you want to see um i actually
said nothing about trump what i said is
that you know trump is gonna on his side
wants his wall
uh and the democrats on their side want
border security without a wall and
they're going to have their fights but
sadly what happens is anyone mentions
the word trump or anyone mentions the
word democrats the opposite side
immediately thinks oh my gosh brad's
saying the horrible thing about mine
i made no comment on who's right or
who's wrong and i think what we have to
do as a culture is take that lesson from
george washington is take that lesson
that where you know what i think we've
lost and i think what you're so right
about you you did him to this
um
is yes there was an early flag and i
meant of course the the current flag as
we know it today but what we've lost
are is the word united in these united
states we've lost that that's a disaster
and i can tell you i've been on book
tour
this week because the first conspiracy
came out this week
and believe it or not there are things
we all agree upon i started on cbs news
i went to my friends at fox news then i
went to my friends at cnm then i went to
my friends who are on npr i was on all
these different things all these
different affiliates all week long
and everything i talked about here i can
tell you
that in all those newsrooms they're all
going yes that's right we've lost these
united states we've lost the idea united
there are things we all agree on
and um no matter what your politics are
and the only reason and the only way
that ever changes
is in leadership you need the right
leadership we need leadership like
george washington people who bring us
together and my friends at fox my
friends on cnn uh there are things we do
uh i think all wish we're different
right now in the culture and i think
taking the lessons as you said so well
of our best heroes of the george
washington's of those who bring us
together i think we'll be far better off
as a country a non-fiction book by our
guest brad meltzer he by the way capped
off our fiction series last year on
c-span 2's book tv are in depth we spent
three hours with him in early december
and if you missed it it's on our website
at csbn.org or check it out at
booktv.org jay from denver colorado
thank you for waiting good morning
hi how are you doing brad uh happy to be
here on c-span i love c-span always
because i feel like i can get the news
like very unbiased
um you know so i'm happy to be here i
would say i'm radically you know
moderate which is a kind of a um
juxtaposition
i like the radically moderate
do you have a question jay one question
at the end and basically it's
essentially
how do we see like say we get like 50
million like cia documents get dropped
in this in a year
how do we kind of see that as a as a way
to like change the truth that we knew
before as a historian
yeah you know and let's talk about that
i do a lot of work in fact when when our
national archives event got shut down
this week i met with the archivist the
united states
um and named david fario who's a
wonderful man who runs the national
archives and i'm obsessed with the
archives i love the archives in fact one
of the things he gave me when i was
there in honor of the first conspiracy
uh is he always brings me one of the
documents they have
and one of those old documents as you
said you know we have ones that get
released all the time all of our
government employees are constantly the
archives works with them to make sure
that every piece of paper every email
everything that comes out that is work
product is saved and catalogs we can
search it and as historians we can look
at it and make sense of it years later
decades later uh and centuries later
even
and one of the things he gave me that
day last two days ago
is
at the beginning of the revolutionary
war
we had what were called
these special loyalty oaths
and what they did was is they asked at
the start of the war they wanted all of
the members in the military to swear an
oath of allegiance that's what the
little words say on it is an oath of
allegiance it looks like a little index
card and the oath of allegiance it says
you know i do solemnly swear you put
your name in there that i will be loyal
to this military to this new country and
one of the things that they wanted to do
was to make sure you were truly there
and what he gave me
was a beautiful copy
they were all numbered number one number
two number three and everyone lined up
to swear they're with age we still do it
with our military today when you you
know when you sign up for the military
you raise your right hand and say i do
solemnly swear i'm going to be loyal to
these united states but he gave me a
copy of number one
and the very first oath of allegiance
that was ever signed for these united
states was signed by george washington
and i love that i love that it started
there what's interesting is number five
which i've actually been into the
archives faults to see
is you know signed by george
washington's number one and there's a
line of men two three four number five
is signed by a man and benedict arnold
and i tell you those stories because
obviously there's there are the bookends
right george washington on one bennett
mcdonald on the other um there's the
work product that starts right there of
what we're going to have to see how we
do and you'll have again that that
goes centuries later to what you see is
50 000 pages or the jfk files that were
released last year
and finally made public
um and the way we go through them is bit
by bit by the same way we built this
country the same way we run this country
the same way it's always going to work
it's just human beings
taking the time to do what they do and
and it's hard but i highly recommend
those who are looking for their history
go to the national archives look at
those documents request them you can ask
for them
so many are open to the public and
that's how we find them because you know
no one person can read 50 000 documents
you got to do it one by one so if
there's a topic you're interested i
highly recommend when the government
opens
get back there and check them out
they're incredible and brad meltzer
the the letters between martha
washington and george washington i know
many were burned after she uh before she
died she did that purposely but uh are
there uh
letters that really give you some
insight into who george washington was
and their relationship
yeah you know what's interesting is
george washington's the most famous
american most recognized american i
think whoever lived
we see him every single day is on the
dollar bill but oddly we know the least
about him as a person and the reason
that is
is because washington is not like
jefferson or john adams who's writing
these you know flowing open loving
letters uh to his wife to his loved ones
telling him every single emotional
feeling he's had george washington does
it very differently always places cards
completely close to his chest
and as a result it's really hard to know
what george washington is thinking in
fact on the day during the first
conspiracy when they hang the man
responsible for the secret plot to kill
george washington again he hangs him in
front of 20 000 people and george
washington barely merits a mention in
his diary if i murdered someone in front
of 20 000 people i'd write dear diary
had a rough day but again george
washington barely mentions it
so it is really difficult and as you
said martha washington burns so many of
the papers
and what's really frustrating is trying
to figure out who george washington is
but the one thing i can tell you is
those letters that you see are
spectacular especially the ones you see
from firsthand when george washington
is first chosen
as our commander-in-chief one of the
first things he does he actually leaves
the room he doesn't want to be there for
it and they can't find him and when they
finally find him he expresses very
clearly that he just doesn't know if
he's up to this task it's not a moment
again of chess beating and saying yes
i'm the one who can save us all
it's a moment where he just says
you know what this is hard work and and
you see immediately from the moment he
enters that public eye as you see
humility and you see modesty remember
when humility and modesty were great
american values we've lost sight of that
now what we do in america today is we we
pay attention to those who are the
loudest
and whether it's on facebook or twitter
or instagram or anywhere else we pay
attention to those who beat their chess
and say look at me look at me
and george washington one thing you take
away from him is that modesty that
feeling in fact the first thing one of
the first things he does when he takes
control of the military
is he doesn't say he's the best at it he
immediately goes and orders books on how
to be a better general and admitting
that you need to learn admitting that
you need to read uh lincoln actually
does the same thing when he takes office
and i think that's a sign of great
strength to me that shows you the depth
of his character and who he is and how
he approaches this new job that he's
taking from flatiron books the first
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
george washington will
joining us from michigan good morning
hey good morning i really love this um
perfect for this morning my family
belonged to the sons and daughters of
the american revolution
we actually still have a town in
pennsylvania
named after us
and according to my grandfather who is
one of the people that you suggest
uh go to the library and look up did
that several years ago and he found our
family history that way um and according
to you know what you said earlier about
them rounding up all the boats and stuff
exactly um they had a barge at the uh in
um in pennsylvania and also helped
washington across the delaware um but on
this national emergency uh deal do you
agree or would you agree that the first
national emergency was when two lanterns
went up in a a church steeple
signifying that the british had landed
and if you ask me today i think we need
three lanterns up there because we're
being invaded by land by air and by sea
and there isn't
there's democrats there's republicans
there's independent but nobody says i'm
an american anymore you're absolutely
right we need you tonight people yeah no
i think that's right listen we have to
get back right we have to stop
identifying ourselves by our parties you
know i on the back of the first
conspiracy you'll see two blurbs
um
and you'll see one from president bill
clinton and you'll see one from
president george h.w bush both great men
but people tell you oh i only like one
of those or you know what their american
presence show respect stop identifying
yourself as a democrat or republican
only because you're every one of us out
there every person listening right now
is way more than that
um and i think what we do right now in
our culture that you hit upon
is you know someone disagrees with you
on social media you unfollow unfriend
and then all you're doing is surrounded
by people who agree with you nothing
good ever comes of that no great leader
ever comes from surrounding yourself
with people who tell you you're the best
and you're great
um and i remember you know my friend
george h.w bush i was at his funeral in
houston
and i remember james baker telling the
story
about how you know he'd always uh
president bush would always say to him
you know tell me what you where you
disagree and they'd have these big
arguments and he said and james baker
said he would tell him passionately why
he thought he was wrong and then
president bush he said always had a
great way
of telling him that he was done hearing
the advice and he was going to go make
his decision he would always say baker
if you're so smart
how come i'm the one who's the president
united states
which is a great way to say it but what
is key part of the story
is the listening to the other side we
have to do that and and that to me is
how we come together you're a hundred
percent right stop identifying yourself
as your political party identify
yourself as an american and you know
what don't just follow your side of the
news
today on social media on television go
look if you're if you watch fox go watch
msnbc if you watch msnbc go watch fox
follow someone who has the opposite
political view of yours
it will make you crazy it will get your
blood boiling you're going to be so
angry
but somewhere in there you're going to
see
that they're just like you every person
you hate and disagree with and don't
like as someone said to me has hopes and
dreams just like you we are human beings
we are americans we need to remember
what we have common rather than what
pulls us apart and to that point from
the book you write the following quote
washington forged more than a new
brotherhood he forged a nation and
proved the one truth at the core of both
the revolution and america itself
that in our lowest moments
we can find our greatest strengths
back to your phone calls kathleen is
joining us dayton ohio good morning
i couldn't agree with your guests more
about
you know
you know talking to people who have
different views in you i went to a trump
rally outside of dayton ohio in 2016 and
i had a sign that said i'm a sanders
supporter and i want to talk to trump
supporters i had a blast i had a blast
you find out that you have
far more in common about equity in
education
uh health care for all and fair pay
and and then even banging on the doors
to the dems this fall which i've done
every almost every election i talked to
trump supporters all the time and had
fabulous conversations you can learn so
much about one another however i want to
ask your guest um i believe you said
that um washington's bodyguards were
were referred to as lifeguards
and that they ended up if i heard you
correctly that they ended up being part
of the conspirators to take his life so
i'm wondering what they were so angry
about
and i i also want to ask c-span to do a
show on
those who have been hiring illegal
immigrants for decades and why they're
not fined in jail and due to do state by
state show us some state by state um
graphs of who who hires and if they're
fine in jail and also um i'd love for
you guys you guys aren't focused ever on
the israeli palestinian conflict anymore
please have phil weiss on
uh from mondo weiss thank you kathleen
we'll get a response brad meltzer
yeah so um
let's go back to the lifeguards who are
uh the bodyguards george washington's
private bodyguards who again are
guarding they guard just to be clear um
the paperwork of george washington they
guard the cash and the money they want
to make sure that that's there and again
they guard his life and they're the ones
in charge of making sure he's safe
imagine them as kind of the original
secret service that you know we always
trace the secret service to the
pinkertons in the civil war but they
actually trace back to this moment to
the lifeguards during the revolutionary
war and it wasn't a grievance that they
had um you'll see when you read the
first conspiracy that what they really
want is money
again the story that we we're a country
founded on legends and myths and the
legends and myths we love most are our
own so the story that we always tell is
again we came together we all believed
in democracy and we took on the british
again a great story but not the true
story uh in reality we were deeply
divided as i mentioned and one of the
things you'll see in the book is the
governor
of new york at the time under british
rule was a man named william tryon the
mayor of new york at the time was a man
named david matthews both of them again
were under british rule and when they
basically lost their jobs when we said
you know what we don't need british rule
anymore we're going to
take get rid of the governor get rid of
the mayor that were assigned to us from
the british
guess what they want their jobs back
they're tired they don't want that at
all and they're the ones who go out and
say
let's see who we can bring back and get
rid of this guy george washington so we
can get our power back so what they do
is they start basically finding people
who want to switch sides and they find
people in the military they find people
who are just ordinary citizens they find
people who are patriots out there and on
the american side and they offer money
and say listen if you come to our side
uh we'll pay you money and the plan the
plot to kill george washington
wasn't just the plot to kill washington
it was that when the british invaded
what was going to happen
is they were going to steal cannons blow
up bridges and again also go after
washington in fact there's a deep debate
some say they're going to kill
washington right there that it was
absolutely an assassination attempt and
others say they were going to just
kidnap him
either way even if they kidnapped him at
george washington's level at that level
of the military one of the things they
do
is they hang you if you're at a lower
level they'll trade you one soldier for
another will take one from their side
they'll take one from ours but at george
washington's level they'll hang you so
either way george washington's life is
in danger
and the sad part is the lifeguards
you'll see in on it there are four
different lifeguards who they switch
some of them for money but some of them
could be just because uh they thought
they were going to lose
we all see of course the american
revolution as we know the ending but
they didn't know the ending back then
and with a country that was deeply
divided
there were moments where it looked like
the british were going to win and you
know what on the american side
we couldn't you know we're paying people
it's not like they were signed up
because they loved democracy democracy
was an idea that took a long time to
catch hold
they came originally because they were
being paid to fight in the military well
we tell these stories today oh these
young people signed up because they were
so passionate about democracy they were
being paid old people signed up they
were so passionate about democracy they
needed money they were being paid too
and yes there were some who've signed up
for democracy but when you're signing up
to be paid
and it looks like your side is about to
lose
guess what and it's still true today no
one wants to be the loser so people
start switching sides you know what the
british look like they're doing better
i'm going to work for them and that's
what happens in the lifeguards you see
people who want money
who see a chance for power and you see
them switch sides on george washington
himself and that's why to me what i love
about the first conspiracy as a book as
as our first non-fiction book
is you don't just get to see the plot
which again is titillating and it's
great to say there's a plot to kill
washington but what you get to see is
how complex the revolutionary war really
was
and i think for me personally
you know it i don't tell you the story
is being complex because it's it's
interesting to take down history i don't
think that's it at all
if it were easy
if the war was easy why would we study
it it was easy it happened easily
but it didn't it happened hard and to me
what's far more important is to study is
when it's hard then the battle is really
amazing it's more amazing than ever so
when you see the real complexity that
was at stake there um i think the
history lesson becomes far more
important and i love all the people out
there this week who have bought the
books not just for themselves or for
their fathers and father-in-laws but i
love all the people that have come to my
signings and said this is the one book
that my son and daughter want to read
that because they want to really see how
it really was back then and the more we
can tell that true story rather than
that whitewashed version
the more great i think you'll see
america really is brad meltzer a quick
follow-up i want to get back to calls
but david mccullough in a c-span
interview said generally speaking
back during the revolutionary war period
about a third of the country wanted to
stay with great britain a third wanted a
fight and a third were indifferent would
you agree with that assessment
a hundred percent it is no different
than we are today right that's exactly
what david mccullough um and obviously
you know as a source in in the book his
books are of course you know 1776 and
others um we looked at very carefully
and i 100 agree we were completely
divided we tell the story we paint a
picture
like at schoolhouse rock where there was
this great american dream but if you
looked at the beginning of the war
um
a third of the people you know loved
democracy a third basically were like
you know what it's just a trade
difference we just need to negotiate a
better deal they don't want to get rid
of the king they just wanted a better
deal they wanted to pay less taxes
so and then the third just was like i
don't care as apathetic as the third is
today
and it's amazing that even back then
which we always want to romanticize and
tell you how great it was as if we all
matched and you know with the the the
fife and the drummer and the and and
you're holding the flag and march
through the street as if we were all
behind them it's just as frustrating
then as it was now watching a third of
the country be completely apathetic to
what was happening and the other two
thirds fighting on different sides of
the issue kind of pointing fingers at
the other and wishing the other would
listen to them we love to think that
we're getting smarter and we're getting
better but the reason we study history
sadly what you realize over and over as
it's attributed to mark twain although
we never said it but uh history doesn't
repeat but it sure does rhyme
let's go to kip who's been patient in
albany new york with brad meltzer who is
joining us from fort lauderdale florida
good morning
good morning um i'm calling from
stephentown just east of uh albany and
the port lauderdale looks awfully good
today
you have no idea i was in washington two
days ago it was freezing um and yes i
will take this weather any day i
apologize to anyone who is uh in snow
c-span totally cursed me by giving me
the beautiful background because now
everyone's all mad that i'm getting to
sit in the nice weather
um a couple questions for you um first
you know you mentioned governor tyrone
there for trying
there was a county in new york state at
one time named trion county and because
of the war they renamed it i think it's
called montgomery county now um
where does benedict arnold fit into your
story
did the events in your in your book
occur before
arnold's betrayal of west point or after
was he one of the conspirators is
your your response brad melvin yeah jose
and let's talk about that sure yeah of
course um you know benedict arnold uh
came later in the war this is at the
start with what what the first
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
george washington really takes place
from uh 1775 1776. arnold of course
comes in later uh but there are and uh
someone i actually wrote another book
that was about benedict darwin i'll give
you my quick favorite story is that when
benedict arnold betrays george
washington they say it's one of the only
times george washington has ever seen
crime and i could never shake that image
of george washington crying and what
benedict arnold does is he quickly
writes a note that is hand delivered by
alexander hamilton to george washington
and it's hand delivered not in song or
in rap by hamilton but it comes to
george washington the letter says three
things it says one
it says don't kill my wife she didn't
know i was in on it bernard mcdonald
says he says two don't kill my staff
they didn't know uh that what i was up
to but he's three and one of the
craziest moments of letter right in
history benedict arnold says to him uh
can i please have my belongings back he
wants his stuff back
as if he's you know the the girlfriend
you know and she wants a record
collection back and
you know george washington amazingly
actually gives it back to him he sends
back his belongings and to this day
nobody knows what's in those belongings
that george washington sends back it is
a mystery still to history
but i love the fact that in the first
conspiracy you get to see that benedict
arnold wasn't the first one who was
plotting against george washington it
actually started way before let's go to
owen joining us from new york city good
morning
yeah hi uh brad uh it's great seeing you
and robin barza to northbound maybe two
alumni
on the no chargers yeah robert and i are
both doing it
no chargers uh
i was wondering when you were doing the
research for the book did you use the
papers at mount vernon or any of the
archives at boston university
or uh yeah let's talk about that yeah
yeah so um you know the research for
this book and full credit when i started
this book i i went to
um pulitzer prize-winning author joseph
ellis and i said to him do you know this
story about a secret plot to kill george
washington and he knew the story in fact
any good washington biography has you
know have a sentence or two maybe a
paragraph a page and a half a footnote
and one of the things that he said to me
is he said this is a story of george
washington's spies
and you can find right now at mount
vernon they'll tell you the exact number
of slaves that george washington owned
but you'll never find all his spies he
said to me that day that by its nature
what you're searching for brad will
forever be elusive but he said you got
to take a shot he says because if it
works you're going to get an amazing
book out of it and if it doesn't you're
going to have an adventure and i knew as
you said
it's all going to depend on that
research
so the first thing i did you know we had
a tv show on the history channel a
number of years ago we did decoded and
one called lost history and we went
looking for the 9 11 flag that the
firefighters raised at ground zero and
many people didn't know that flag went
missing
on the tv show we went looking for it
we put the word out we offered a reward
and and four days after our episode
aired a man walked into a fire station
in washington dc
uh i'm sorry in washington state and
said i saw the show lost history and i
want to return the flag this is the flag
that the firefighters raised to ground
zero and everyone you know we we uh
spent nearly a year authenticating it
with the former head of the fbi as our
crimes union we found the flag we
brought it back authenticated it we were
able on the 15th anniversary of 911 to
unveil it in the 911 museum where it's
still on display i highly recommend
people go to the museum it's inspiring
to see but one of the things that you
know everyone's like oh brad thank you
for doing that but it wasn't just me
there was an amazing incredible staff of
lost history that made it happen and i
tell you that story because when i
realized i had to do research
the executive producer of our show lost
history as a man named josh mensch best
researcher and best writer we had and
when i knew i was going to go down this
rabbit hole of looking for the secret
plot to kill george washington the first
call i made is to josh mensch who worked
on the show and helped find the 911 flag
with me and i said listen i'd love to
find this we're going to have to do the
research are you up for it and he and i
were the ones who tackled it with our
friend barnett schechter a great
washington expert
and we love to picture ourselves or i'll
speak to myself i picture myself as
indiana jones i crawl through the
cobwebs i hum the theme song and i
slowly get to find these arcane facts
which i get to deliver to you but it's
not like indiana jones at all the
reality is is so much of this stuff is
online we used a lot from the national
archives especially from the new york
archives the new york historical society
and the files especially of the new york
provincial congress
no one just wants to read them we took
the time to read them and what really
cracked it open in terms of sources is
you'll see in the book we were able to
find the actual transcripts from the
secret tribunal where they tried the man
who was hung for the plot to kill george
washington and again that man was he
that man was uh uh was well you want to
reveal him in the book but his name was
uh was they call it the hickey plot and
hickey himself was one of the lifeguards
and when they hung thomas hickey
one of the things that you'll see is
there was a trial of course before it
and it's not in it wasn't a public trial
it was in a secret tribunal by the
committee on conspiracies and when they
hung thomas hickey at the time
we got to finally see and i didn't know
if we were going to have anything when
we started looking for this but when we
found the transcripts of the hickey
trial that's where it all cracked
completely open for us because one of
the things that happened in that moment
is there's the transcript you can see
right there what they accused him of who
the witnesses was there were people who
were speaking against him and now was on
the record and once you get that the
whole book cracked open
nancy joining us from springfield
virginia good morning
good morning mr uh uh and mr yelp sir i
really enjoy all this and i live in fair
festival which is not far from mount
vernon and i'm a diplomat
uh when washington and jefferson
signed the declaration of independence
or i guess therefore wasn't it
uh they were
of about 250 people who owned the entire
state of virginia and west virginia
territories but i'm talking about that
what you said about uh democrats and
republicans and immigration and the wall
and what's going on i'd like to propose
a hamiltonian solution because we sell
more more wall bonds
because we can do both i think we need
the united states of central america
with mexico and those seven smaller
countries to panama going together in a
federation because as dr king said
teaching is learning twice and we teach
them how to have a federal system
uh then we will benefit from it thank
you thank you for the call you know what
i love this is why i love yeah i love
you what i love about c-spin is you can
have a caller who considers herself a
washingtonian
says she's i'm sorry jeffersonian right
but she has a hamiltonian solution god
bless america that there are people who
still believe uh you know in in those
people and and what i'll say and because
i it was hard to hear breaking up but
i'll tell you my favorite um
jeffersonian story that has to do with
this one um because as you mentioned the
declaration of independence is um a
couple a couple months ago
uh we all know a couple weeks ago former
president george h.w bush passed away he
was a dear friend of mine
and
barbara bush also president bush and
barbara bush used to read my books and i
loved mrs bush very much for what she
did for literacy around the country one
of her big things when she fought for
literacy is she felt like the american
dream was achieved when we teach
families how to read and not just the
kids but the parents and she was
dedicated dedicated her life to teaching
people how to read
who especially were foreign speakers who
did not speak english who were
immigrants she said that's how we
achieve the american dream not by
attacking immigrants but by arming them
with american ideals and especially with
reading
is how you arm them with with some of
the great things that america has to
offer i should say and when president
bush died we were honoring barbara bush
at a literacy event a few weeks before
and this is now a few months ago
and at this point we knew it was
happening with president bush we knew
how sick he was
and i didn't want to ever tell this
story when he passed away but i can
actually tell it now
and you'll see why and they were i found
out they were bringing in some of
president bush's um some of his favorite
writers to read to him
and they said to me brad would you like
to read to president bush and i said i'd
be honored to do that and my wife and i
were in kennebunkport maine and we went
to president bush's office and they
warned me they said he's only going to
be awake
for about 10 minutes he's sleeping a lot
these days
um so he's going to fall asleep on you
my wife of course said don't worry
brad's used to putting people to sleep
with his books he does it all the time
and of course my wife has to make that
joke and we go in to president bush's
office and the secret service leave and
it's just president bush my wife myself
and his service dog selly
and we know this is the end and we're
sitting in his office we see the ocean
right outside the window
and i can see on his desk there's a
stack of about five books
and i had sent them a copy of the first
conspiracy nearly a year ago about eight
months ago
which he read and he blurbed for us of
course but i can see that there's a copy
of the first conspiracies on his desk it
is dog-eared it looks like it's been
read a thousand times i can see the
post-it notes and where you know what
page he's on and as if he's read it over
and over again and i pick up the book
and i and i say to him you know i
actually brought my own copy i said do
you want to read this sir and at this
point he's more nodding and he'd be
and so i picked my favorite passage from
the first conspiracy to read to him
and the passage i picked was where
george washington
uh it's presented for the first time
where the declaration of independence is
read to the troops for the first time
with george washington
and i said that's the passage i want to
read and i'm reading along the chapter
and sure enough president bush falls
asleep
and but i want to finish the chapter and
make sure he gets the end and i'm
getting toward the end and i get to
those words where the declaration of
independence is read and washington's
there and it's being presented to the
troops in 1776 for the first time and i
get to those words right
we hold those truth these truths to be
self-evident
that all men are created equal and as i
say the words
president bush's eyes open up and he is
locked on me and as anyone who's been to
a sick bed in a hospital with a loved
one you know those moments where they
pop open their eyes and there's pure
clarity he's right there as if the words
of the declaration of independence are
his actual lifeblood as if it's his iv
in that moment
and i get to the end of the chapter of
the book
and he's still locked on me and i said
you want another chapter
and then we read another chapter another
and another
and an hour goes by
an hour where he's locked on it and you
know i think
for me
you know it was so humbling
so humbling to be able to read
about america's first president to at
that moment in time our oldest living
president it was one of the most
humbling moments i'll ever have in my
life but when my friend president bush
passed away
one of the things i noticed over and
over again was one word that were in all
the tributes to him and it was this word
decency
decency
and it wasn't just because it was a
decent man he was but it's because this
country today is starving for decency
we're starving for it again no politics
about it whatever side you're on we've
lost a sense of decency and that decency
always starts with leadership you want
it back you got to find the leadership
who brings it back and i love that i got
to have that final moment with president
bush and i got to shake his hand i got
to say goodbye
and he gave me that gift and so many
other gifts i'll carry with me forever i
you know there are many things i love
about the first conspiracy
but having that moment with president
bush was absolutely first class and top
of the list we have about a minute left
time for one more call john you get the
last word if you could be brief from
mobile alabama
okay um
unfortunately i'm last call but
as a black man i find it disheartening
disingenuous you're not speaking the
whole thing about george washington
james madison thomas jefferson andrew
jackson
how they enrich their lives off the back
of men women and children so tell the
whole truth i appreciate about george
washington because he's not heroic i'm
sure in the eyes of every black person
and even every native american that's
lived in this country today and that's
the reason why we have a lot of
divisiveness in this country thank you
john and brian let's talk about that no
and i'm glad yeah i'm i'm glad you
brought that up um one of the things was
very vital to us one of the chapters we
put in this book
is dealing with george washington
slavery and and how we own slaves and
how um you know
that
but one thing i do want to want to say
to you is i appreciate you saying that
because you're right um but we should
never ever be judged any of us whether
it's george washington yourself or
myself by our worst day none of us are
who we are on our worst day there is a
wonderful book that's out right now
about how george washington went after a
runaway slave you should read it it'll
tell you more about them none of us are
perfect if you're looking for someone
perfect only god is that's it every one
of us is flawed
and don't judge people by their worst
moment we are our worst moments and we
are our best moments we are a complexity
we are all amazing and terrified we're
all wonderful and we're all scared we
are all awful and we are all amazing
sometimes in the same day sometimes in
the same hour so uh i appreciate your
call and i appreciate every single
person as i go on book tour for the next
week i'm going around the country still
who's been supporting the first
conspiracy the secret plot to kill
george washington i really appreciate
all the love for the book and we are
glad for your time very quickly this is
book number what for you
uh it is actually the first book that is
non-fiction i've written 12 thrillers 16
kids books in the im series but this is
number one so i counted always as number
one uh in nonfiction i've never done
nonfiction before and i never had a book
that i really wanted to dedicate
the entire subject to until i found this
one about our first president it's
called the first conspiracy the secret
plot to kill george washington brad
meltzer as always thank you for being
with us please come back again
always thank you my friend
and a reminder we're back tomorrow
morning with c-span's washington journal
we'll focus much more on the shutdown
now entering week four the longest
shutdown in history we'll also take a
look at your money one billion dollars
for career and educational development
what that means for those in the
workforce and finally we'll talk to the
policy director from the american
federation of government employees
jackie simon that's tomorrow morning
newsmakers is next be sure to check out
our programming on c-span 2's book tv
this weekend and american history tv on
c-span 3. we appreciate you joining us
on a very snowy sunday morning here in
the nation's capital enjoy the rest of
your weekend have a great week ahead
[Music]
here's a look at some of our programming
today on c-span the 23rd day of the
government shutdown